المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في مدينه دافوس
السويسريه يعود هذه السنه في نسخته
الشتويه لاول مره منذ الجائحه العام
الماضي اقيم في شهر مايو ما الذي يميز
دابوس هذا العام انا لارى حبيب لحصلت
الضوء على خمسه امور اساسيه اولا عنوان
المنتدى التعاون في عالم منقسم كوبريشن
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان العالم منقسم بسبب
الازمات الصحيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
التي لحقت به مثل حرب اوكرانيا
المعيشه والتباطؤ الاقتصادي كلها ازمات
مترابطه وحلها يستدعي التعاون بين
القطعتين العام والخاص ثانيا الحضور
الحضور اقوى من اجتماعات مايو وهناك عدد
قياسي من الرؤساء التنفيذيين اكثر من 600
رئيس تنفيذي الوجوه التي عادت الى دافوس
هذا العام رؤساء جي في مرجان
غيره ثالثا المنتدى الذي سيطرت عليه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه في اجتماعات مايو حارس
هذا العام ان يعطي ايضا اهميه لتداعيات
هذه الحرب الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسي يشارك
عبر الفيديو وزوجته حضوريا اما المليارات
الروس فغائبين للسنه الثانيه على التوالي
رابعا الحضور الصيني جيد وعلى راسهم نائب
رئيس الحكومه ولكن اجراءات الحج الصحيه
التي كانت موضوعها وترقب راس السنه
الصينيه في الثانيه والعشرين من شهر يناير
حتى من عدد المشاركين خامسا واخيرا هناك
قريه افتراضيه فيلم
مسؤولين عبر الافاتار وهناك جناح لشركه
ارامكو طارت فيه مشاريعه من الطاقه
المتجدده الهدف من هذه القريه ايجاد حلول
لبعض مشاكل البيئه